سنتحول الى كارمن كارمن روسيا تقول انها
دمرت اليات غربيه للجيش الاوكراني في محور
الزبولوجيا تفاصيل اكثر حول ذلك
بالعموم اخر تحديثات الروسيه حول التطورات
في الجنوب والشرق
نعم سهام قبل الخوض في تفاصيل الميدان
هناك حرب اعلاميه تشنها روسيا بكثافه فيما
خص الاسلحه الغربيه التي تدمرها في ميادين
القتال اخر هذه المقاطع المصوره نشرت قبل
قليل وتظهر ما وصف هنا بمجزره الدبابات
وتظهر 12 دبابه برادلي امريكيه مدمره
بالكامل قالت انها في جنوبي دانيتوا مقطع
مصور اخر قبل قليل ايضا تم نشره من داخل
احدى دبابات اثنان الالمانيه احد الجنود
وعدد من الجنود الروس دخلوا الى تلك
الدبابه يظهرون ايضا المدافع التي
يستخدمونه والقذائف بالاحرى التي تستخدم
داخل هذه الدبابه هذا في اخر المقاطع
المصوره التي تنتشر بكثافه وفي الايام
الماضيه سهام مع استعار القتال على
الجبهات وضبط يمكن القول وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه على نشر مثل هذه المقاطع المصوره
بالعوده الى الميدان يمكن القول ان هذا
الخط او هذا الشريط الممتد من شمال بخمه
وصولا الى من شمال دانياسك في التحديد
وصولا الى جنوب وايضا بالتقاطع ما عجبهه
هذا خط مشتعل في باخت تتحدث وزاره الدفاع
عن صدها هجمات وعن عدم قدره القوات
الاوكرانيه على اختراق دفاعاتها في تلك
المنطقه التي كانت قد اعلنت السيطره عليها
قبل فتره فيها عدد من الجبهات المشتعله
والمقتال فيها محتدم بشكل كبير كان في
افدي افكا شمالا او حتى في اوغليدار جنوبا
وفي مارينكا حيث تقاتل القوات الشيشانيه
مع القوات الروسيه هذا الامر سهام يرتد
على داخل مدينه ووسط مدينه دانياتك بقصف
اوكراني اليوم تصادت الدفاعات الجويه لعدد
من القذائف داخل مدينه دانيتك هذا القصف
كما اشرنا في الايام الماضيه يتكث ف بشكل
كبير هذا الامر يمتد ايضا الى ذا فالوجيا
حيث تقول القوات الروسيه والمتحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ايكوناشنكوف قال ان
هناك صد لعدد من الهجمات بالاضافه الى
بخموت وتحدث عن تكبيد القوات الاوكرانيه
خسائر في العتاد فلنستمع لابرز ما قاله
كنشنكوف
في محاور القتال بمقاطعه
تم صد جميع هجمات العدو من خلال الاجراءات
الشجاعه للقوات الروسيه بلغ اجمالي خسائر
القوات الاوكرانيه في هذه الاتجاهات في
اليوم الاخير 300 جندي وتسعه دبابات في
مدينه نجحت القوات الروسيه خلال النهار في
صد خمس هجمات للعدو في اتجاه مستوطنتي
كليشيفكا
وخلال القتال في هذا الاتجاه تم القضاء
على اكثر من 200 جندي اوكراني كما اسقطت
دفاعاتنا الجويه في منطقه مستوطنه
بلاتونوفكا في مقاتله اوكرانيه